We can make sure this will never happen simply by sorting our data,
using the built in JavaScript.sort function to find on all arrays, and
make sure that our nested data set is in the correct order before we bind it
in our data binding function.
To sort our data, the elements I've nested get passed to
our call back accessor function two at a time, a and b.
And based on the return value from this function,
either a gets placed before b or b gets placed before a.
If the return value is less than zero, a gets placed first or
rather, the first argument to the function.
If the return value is greater than zero, b gets placed first.
Or rather, the second argument to the function gets placed first.
And if what gets returned is zero then there's no change.
Simply leave a and b in the order that they originally were in.
In our case, if the attendance of b is greater than the attendance of a,
the return value will be positive and b will get placed first.
Thus having the effect of drawing the larger attendances first.
If a happens to have a larger attendance.
Then b, the return value will be negative.
In this case, a will get placed first.
And again, this is correct since a would have the larger attendance.
And now that our map is on a take shape,
we have geographies of countries plotted as well as data,
we can begin adding animation to encode the passage of time.